على ركام الحرب الجاريه في السودان انصار
الرئيس السابق عمر البشير يبحثون عن موطئ
قدم فالحرب فرصتهم الوحيده وستحدد مصيرهم
انصار البشير وحزب المؤتمر الوطني
الاخواني توعدوا بنشر الفوضى في البلاد
قطعا للطريق امام اي اتفاق تتاسس بموجبه
حكومه مدنيه فالحكومه المدنيه الديمقراطيه
تعني بالاساس عدم عودتهم للحكم مجددا
بعدما قادوا البلاد لمده 30 عاما بقبضه من
حديد
هؤلاء شنوا حمله تحريض واسعه لاشعال الحرب
وما ان اشتعلت حتى ظلوا يطالبون
باستمرارها بل وصل الامر باحد خطبائهم لحد
اصدار فتوى بقتل المدنيين المعارضين
لتواصل الاشتباكات الحمله استهلها القيادي
الحاج ادم يوسف محرضا انصار حزبه اذ حثهم
على مواجهه القوى المؤيده للحكم المدني
وانتخابات او مظاهرات تحصل
في الشارع
القيادي في الحركه والوالي السابق الذي
اشتهر بمواقفه المتطرفه انس عمر وصف
الحكومه المدنيه الانتقاليه بالفاشله
كاشفا عن دورهم في اسقاطها ومهددا في
الوقت ذاته باسقاط اي حكومه مدنيه
[موسيقى]
الرابعه والخامسه والحكومه
[تصفيق]
اما نائب البشير الاسبق ابراهيم محمود فقد
وجه انصار حزبه بالاستعداد للنزول الى
الميدان في حال توقيع الاتفاق السياسي
النهائي نحن نقول الان استعدوا يا اخواننا
هذا الاتفاق لوالن كل الشعب السوداني لازم
يكون في الميدان
انصار حزب المؤتمر الوطني الذي تزعمه
البشير رفعوا شعارا جديدا يقوم على تخوين
كل من ينادي بوقف الحرب حمله الترهيب
والتخوين والتشويه والتخويف هذه تستهدف
قاده القوى المدنيه التي اسقطت نظام
البشير بالثوره الشعبيه في ربيع العام
انصار البشير نشطوا بعيده توقيع الاتفاق
الايطالي اتشلوا حمله تحريض ضخمه ضد هذا
الاتفاق الذي يقضي بتسليم السلطه للمدنيين
التحليلات والوقائع تشير الى ان جماعه
الاخوان وانصار البشير يعتبرون الحرب
الدائره معركتهم الاخيره يلقون فيها بكل
اسلحتهم الامر الذي يجعل سيناريو الحرب
الوحيده المتاحه امام بقائهم فلا خيار اخر
لهم في مواجهه الرفض الشعبي الواسع
لعودتهم الى الحكم من جديد
ما يحدث في السودان ليس حربا بين جنرالين
هناك اطراف لعبت دورا في تصعيد المواجهه
وتستفيد من هذه الازمه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات